[Musik]
heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid ja
während wir pläne schmieden fürs
wochenende die sonne scheint man freut
sich aufs wochenende frühling liegt in
der luft geht der krieg in der ukraine
unvermindert weiter und die lage ist
weiterhin mit einem wort muss man es so
sagen dramatisch wir schauen uns diese
bilder an zerstörung nimmt immer größere
ausmaße an nach wie vor gibt es keine
gesicherten flucht korridore dennoch
sind menschen zu hunderttausenden auf
der flucht und es fehlt an allem
verpflegung wasser medikamente wie lange
die soldaten auch das geschehen auf den
straßen bestimmen niemand weiß es und
auch nicht was dieser krieg auf
generationen hin anrichten wird
wie der westen diesen krieg putins krieg
sieht da muss man sagen das ist ziemlich
einhellig die eu die nato sind so eng
zusammen wie schon lange nicht mehr aber
wie sehen russlanddeutsche putins krieg
darüber wollen wir reden heute und sind
natürlich wie immer an euren meinungen
an euren informationen interessiert ihr
gehört gerne im chat schreiben oder in
der hier eingeblendeten adresse an zdf
heute - live at zdf de und wir sehen
schon auf dem monitor wir haben zwei
gesprächsgäste heute die erste sira
peter zugeschaltet aus mannheim einen
schönen guten abend
sie sind in kasachstan geboren und leben
seit 1992 in deutschland sie haben
literaturwissenschaft psychologie
studiert arbeiten als freie
marketingberaterin und journalistin und
haben seit 2000 sind jetzt 17 im fokus
russlanddeutsche themen vielleicht
fangen wir damit mal an weil das hatten
wir auch in der überschrift und haben
auch selbst hier darüber diskutiert ist
dieser begriff russland deutschland
russlanddeutsche angemessen ja also wir
brauchen einfach begriffen über dinge
sprechen zu können und der begriff
russlanddeutsche hat sich mittlerweile
etabliert auch wenn ihn nicht alle gerne
benutzen und um einem missverständnis
vorab zu greifen oder 1 auszulöschen
dass russland inbegriff russlanddeutsche
bezieht sich nicht auf das land russland
wie wir es heute kennen sondern auch das
zaristische russland das damals
deutschstämmige menschen so wie meine
großeltern mit der des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts ausgewandert sind bei den
bildern die wir vorhin gesehen haben und
den nachrichten die sie jetzt seit über
zwei wochen hören wie geht es ihnen
schlecht also ich fühle mich
also eine sehr sehr schwere trauer hat
sich einfach auf meine schultern gelegt
das ist ein großer schmerz den sehr sehr
viele russlanddeutsche empfinden und bei
mir kommt hinzu dass sich im vergangenen
jahr in odessa gelebt habe dort als
stadtschreiberin viele ukrainische
münchen kennengelernt habe und mir
momentan sehr große sorgen um sie machen
und zum anderen sind auch meine
großeltern aus der ukraine deportiert
worden und somit die ukraine auch
irgendwie ein teil meiner identität und
auch meiner heimat obwohl ich ja dort
gar nicht geboren wurde diese
nachrichten die sie hören diese
bekanntschaften die sie haben diese
ganzen informationen die auf sie
einprasseln was macht das mit
also ich versuche tatsächlich nur noch
radio zu hören und nicht zu informieren
und tatsächlich gar keine visuellen
eindrücken mir zu holen weil mich das
komplett aus der banken wird also jedes
bild das ich zufällig in social media
oder sonstwo macht mich vollkommen
traurig weil ich einfach weiß wie
dieses land ja schon vor dem
angriffskrieg war und wie sehr es jetzt
leidet und das macht mich betroffen und
ich bin ja ich möchte etwas tun und
meinen freunden helfen und bin die ganze
zeit irgendwie am handy und versuche zu
vermitteln und auch menschen tatsächlich
nach deutschland zu bringen und ja dass
das einfach sehr sehr schwierig und ich
glaube dass er sehr sehr vielen
russlanddeutschen aktuell so geht die
sie vor gut zwei wochen kurz davor noch
gedacht dass es derart eskalieren nein
auf gar keinen fall also vor allem weil
ich ja das vor kurzem selbst in dem land
gelebt habe und das leben der alltag war
ganz ganz ähnlich wie zu hier mann ist
ins theater gegangen in cafés hat
freunde getroffen und natürlich hat der
krieg eine rolle gespielt aber er war so
weit weg von thessa und auch von allen
anderen städten in der ukraine er hat
einfach im osten des landes
stattgefunden und nicht mittendrin und
deswegen hätte ich das nicht für möglich
gehalten ich hätte nein
ein kremlsprecher beklagt heute einen
gefährlichen hass auf russen im westen
russland erwartet dass andere stadt mit
ihren äußerungen nicht weiter einen
boden bereiten für hass und rousseau
phobie so drückt er sich aus wollen wir
jetzt gleich darüber reden aber schauen
uns vielleicht vorher mal an wie
russlanddeutsche diese tage derzeit
erlebt
wir sind in lahr auch abschätzig klein
moskau genannt denn etwa 10.000
russlanddeutsche leben hier knapp ein
viertel der bevölkerung eigentlich sehen
sie sich längst gut integrierter teil
deutschlands doch jetzt scheint etwas
ins wanken zu geraten das hat mir
erzählt dass ein kind in der schule wird
gemobbt weil er russisch ich empfand
mich bis zum kriegs anfang als deutsche
und dann habe ich überlegt eigentlich
sind wir hier als russen immer noch
stempel drauf und fertig nicht alle
wollen mit uns reden nicht alle haben
anfeindungen selbst erlebt doch viele
machen sich gedanken auch kirill maslow
er wird in der stadt bald eine
tanzschule eröffnen vor kurzem entdeckte
er schmierereien die scheibe beschädigt
er vermutet einen zusammenhang mit dem
krieg die polizei ermittelt jetzt bei
kirin lösen die schmierereien erinnerung
aus von der anfangszeit in deutschland
als jetzt fremd galten
das ist nicht mein krieg und dann kann
es nicht ändern aber manche leute 3 und
sich nicht mal mehr russisch zu sprechen
und eine eskalation design was können
wir hierfür in einer whatsapp gruppe
sammeln sie in der eigenen community
anfeindungen die genauen quellen oft
unklar auch manipulationen von
kremltreuen russlanddeutschen nicht
ausgeschlossen
wir sprechen immer wieder von putins
krieg auch der kanzler und andere
benutzen diesen begriff auch unglaublich
nicht irgendwie stimmung zu machen gegen
russland sondern wirklich zu sagen wer
ist aggressor und trotzdem gehen sie
damit ist dass putins krieg
der einen seite gehe ich dann mit ich
hab selbst verwandte in russland ich
gerne menschen die in russland leben und
ich weiß dass sie diesen krieg nicht
möchten und deswegen ist es einerseits
richtig diesen begriff zu verwenden
auf der anderen seite habe ich viele
kontakte in die ukraine und eine meine
freundin hat mir vorhin geschrieben ja
als dass putins krieg aber putin ist
nicht derjenige der die bomben abwirft
er ist nicht derjenige der tatsächlich
sein gewehr auf die bevölkerung richtet
und
ich verstehe einfach beides aber zu sehr
wichtig zu differenzieren weil man muss
ja auch bedenken dass viele menschen die
in deutschland russischsprachige sind ja
auch oftmals ukrainische wurzeln haben
können weil 90 prozent der ukraine
selbst russisch sprach ich sind und es
ist sehr sehr wichtig dass menschen auf
gar keinen fall ja einfach
pauschalisierend so dargestellt werden
als würden sie diesen krieg befürworten
nur weil sie eine sehr tolle sprache
beherrschen und zwar das russische sie
haben ja von auch die beispiele gesehen
und gehört wie ist denn der zustand in
der community wenn man das so sagen kann
wie welches bild ergibt sich da für sie
es ist ein bild das sehr viele
unterschiedliche bilder beinhaltet also
ich kann klar sagen dass die
allermeisten menschen die
russischsprachige sind und in
deutschland leben und die meisten davon
sind eben russlanddeutsche dass sie
gegen diesen krieg sind von diesen
menschen gibt es einige die trotzdem den
krieg nachvollziehen können im sinne von
japan muss ich werde aber dennoch die
allermeisten sind gegen den krieg gegen
putins politik und engagieren sich
derzeit sehr sehr stark dafür dass
menschen die hier in deutschland
ankommen gut aufgenommen werden und
engagieren sich auch in dem sinne dass
bald frieden einkehrt dass sie auf
demonstrationen gehen dass sie die auch
den druck auf die regierung erhöhen weil
unsere regierung muss handeln und ich
meine damit nicht dass man direkt
truppen in das land schickt weil ich
glaube gewalt erzeugt gegengewalt ich
glaube nicht dass es eine lösung ist
aber wir können auf wirtschaftlicher
ebene agieren und beispielsweise mit dem
gas hand von unserer seite zu drehen
dann jetzt vielleicht ungemütlich aber
dafür können wir zum frieden beitragen
so zumindest meine hoffnung sie
betreiben auch den aussiedler podcast
steppen kinder
welche resonanz bekommen sie darauf auch
jetzt speziell in diesen tagen wenn es
darum geht aus dem westen vielleicht
durch doch eine russische brille auf das
zu schauen was da passiert
also die
meisten zu hören denn unseres podcasts
sind ähnlich eingestellt wie man podcast
partner and in marketing und ich also
dass wir im grunde sehr liberal denken
und versuchen uns aus verschiedenen
quellen zu informieren und eben nicht
die lügen glauben die das russische
staatsfernsehen verbreitet und trotzdem
nehmen wir auch verunsicherung war also
gerade wenn es zu fällen von
diskriminierung kommt also
beispielsweise dass schüler von lehrern
ermahnt werden sie sollen doch bitte
nicht mehr russisch sprechen wir nehmen
das wahr wir nehmen das auch ernst aber
wir merken auch dass unglaublich viel
desinformation kursiert in telegramm
gruppen bei water beiden krasniqi das
ist das äquivalent zu facebook und da
werden einfach gezielt informationen
gestreut um die russischsprachigen
menschen in deutschland aufzuhetzen
mittlerweile auch gegen die geflüchteten
ukrainerin in unserem land schauen wir
gleich genauer auf die community aber
vorher noch mal schnell ein beitrag mit
ein paar fakten was man darüber wissen
muss
die alexandrowka in potsdam preußens
könig ließ die blockhaus siedlung vor
200 jahren für einwanderer aus russland
bauen 100 jahre später kam die erste
einwanderer welle in den 1920 er jahren
flohen aus der sowjetunion
hunderttausende gegner der
oktoberrevolution nur wenig bekannt nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg blieben fast
250.000 russische kriegsgefangene
überläufer und zwangsarbeiter in den
folgenden nachkriegsjahrzehnten kamen
dann nur noch wenige meist dissidenten
wie der schriftsteller lew kopelew
ein russischer supermarkt in berlin
russlanddeutsche jüdische und russische
auswanderer kamen nach dem ende des
kommunismus vor allem in den 90er jahren
für einen neuanfang heute leben in
deutschland mehr als drei millionen
menschen aus ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
und deren nachkommen schätzungsweise 2,2
millionen von ihnen sprechen im alltag
russisch
knapp drei millionen wie gehört wie
homogen heterogen ist diese gruppe es
ist ja nicht eine gruppe sondern wie
setzt sie sich zusammen und was ist
sozusagen der kleinste gemeinsame nenner
aus ihrer sicht
einen menschen aus dem post aus ländern
die nach deutschland gekommen sind die
meisten sind von ihnen russlanddeutsche
sind in welchem etwa 90 prozent und der
gemeinsame nenner ist auf jeden fall
dieser erfahrung in der sowjetunion und
gelebt zu haben und das prägt natürlich
auch mich also ich bin zwar im
kleinkindalter hergekommen aber dennoch
habe ich natürlich viele eindrücke
mitgenommen ansonsten ist die gruppe
wahnsinnig hetero gehen also angefangen
bei der politischen einstellung bis zu
sprachkenntnissen und
integrationswillen und
integrationserfolg deswegen ist es immer
so schwierig über die russlanddeutschen
zu sprechen weil wir einfach so so
unterschiedlich sind und deswegen ist
auch so wichtig dass wir jetzt
miteinander sprechen und einen
differenzierteren blick darauf zu werfen
wir gehen wir dann noch weiter vor was
was sind denn die unterschiedlichen
merkmale oder worauf kommt es an es ist
eine altersfrage eine generationsfrage
eine bildungsfrage oder was sind
kriterien die für sie entscheiden sind
ja das alter spielt auf jeden fall auch
eine rolle ich habe den eindruck dass
beispielsweise in aktuellen situationen
eher ältere menschen
russische staatsfernsehen konsumieren
also nicht jetzt plötzlich sondern
einfach schon in den vergangenen jahren
und deswegen wirkt die propaganda jetzt
das ist viel auch mit den
sprachkenntnissen zu tun hat also wenn
jemand eben nicht so gut deutsch gelernt
hat dann hat er auch nicht in zugang zu
deutschsprachigen medien also ist das
oftmals eine generationsfrage
andererseits ist auch vielleicht eine
einstellungsfrage und hätten auch ganz
viel mit den ersten erfahrungen zusammen
in deutschland also wenn man hergekommen
ist als spätaussiedler aussiedler und
die erfahrung gemacht hat nicht
angenommen zu sein als deutscher und man
hat sich in der sowjetunion aber immer
als deutscher gefühlt wurde ja auch
deswegen diskriminiert und wenn man
diese abweisung erfährt oder auch eine
gewisse schmach ablehnung oder ja auch
ablehnung weil die bildungsabschlüsse
beispielsweise nicht anerkannt worden
sind diese erfahrungen diese demütigung
dieses bei manchen tief und ich glaube
dass putins propaganda es schafft diese
gefühle auch was zu machen in diesem
moment und sie zu aktivieren weil er ja
auch diese schmach fühlt vom westen
nicht anerkannt form zu sein und
vielleicht ist das auch ein grund warum
sich manche verstanden fühlen aber
genauso gut gibt es jüngere bußmann
deutschsprachige menschen die
putins propaganda hörig sind oder das
zum teil glauben also dass ganz
unterschiedlich es hat aber auch viel
mit sozialisation zu tun und auch mit
dem alter teilweise auch mit dem
bildungsstand das ist glaube ich ein
sehr wichtiger punkt auch um putin zu
verstehen und auch um in die in die
zukunft zu schauen wenn man sich denn
die mühle geben will putin zu verstehen
dass sie sich durch den westen so
gekränkt fühlt alles kein grund führen
krieg klar aber man muss ja trotzdem
schauen was was treibt den und wie kommt
man aus dieser spirale wieder raus
was heißt das für diejenigen die so
ähnlich ticken oder die das aufnehmen
diese dieses denken und und diese
propaganda die davor gelebt wird was ist
aus ihrer sicht eine möglichkeit
tatsächlich diese spirale zu
durchbrechen und das der westen muss man
sich auch selbstkritisch fragen nicht so
dasteht wie besserwisser wir können es
besser wir wissen es besser wir haben
die moral auf unserer seite
also ist es sehr schwierig die menschen
zu überzeugen die diesen
ja die der version des krämer krimis
schon so lange glauben also ich da komme
ich auch an meine grenzen ist es einfach
zu schwierig weil die propaganda seit
vielen vielen jahren gewirkt hat und
jetzt einfach so massiv einstreut über
verschiedenste kanäle
ich glaube ist es trotzdem wichtig sich
nicht abzuschotten und irgendwie den
dialog zu suchen und ich merke auch bei
vielen menschen auch im eigenen umfeld
das sie so in den ersten kriegstagen
jetzt vor zwei wochen so total
euphorisch waren und jakutien das ist
ein starker mann und er bringt jetzt
eine ordnung in der ukraine und den gibt
es den leuten besser und mittlerweile
gut dann jedoch zurück und verstehen
dass bei viele dinge vielleicht doch
nicht schlüssig sind und deswegen ist es
einfach wichtig dass medien weiterhin
ihre arbeit fortsetzen und ist es auch
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir weiterhin
journalistinnen vor ort in russland und
in der ukraine die möglichkeit geben aus
diesen ländern zu berichten und sie
darin unterstützen also ich glaube
dialog ist einfach weiterhin ganz
wichtig und zwar auf allen ebenen in der
politik und genauso in der
mehrheitsgesellschaft
sie haben vorhin ja auch von der nicht
homogen sondern sehr heterogenen gruppe
gesprochen das heißt das denn wenn es
generationen fragen sind auch innerhalb
von familien von von menschen die hier
leben und auf das was da passiert
schauen und wenn da nicht einigkeit
herrscht oder oder risse jetzt durch
familien gehen ja es interesse also es
sind gravierende einschnitte in vielen
familien ich habe unmittelbar vor dem 24
februar in ein titel für die zeit
geschrieben wo es genau darum ging also
ich habe mit verschiedenen
russlanddeutschen gesprochen und sie
dazu befragt wie geht ihr damit um wenn
eure eltern beispielsweise oder andere
verwandte mehr putins fernsehen glauben
als euch wie geht ihr damit um und da
war schon da zustand so dass sie gesagt
haben es eskaliert dann schnell man kann
nicht mehr sachlich diskutieren das ist
alles so emotional weil eben die
propaganda mit so vielen emotionalen
bildern spielt und dieser zustand hat
sich jetzt natürlich dramatisch
verschlechtert seit dem angriffskrieg
ich weiß bei vielen familien ist es
nicht mehr möglich dass dass gespräche
stattfinden das verbrechen einfach tagt
ab und blockiert sich gegenseitig
airports app oder auf anderen messenger
diensten und das ist dass das
fürchterlich das ist sehr sehr schlimm
es ist einfach bei vielen gar keinen
dialog mehr möglich aber bei der
mehrheit trotzdem und es gibt um die
ältere generation jetzt kurz in schutz
zu nehmen es gibt viele ältere
russlanddeutsche die absolut liberal
eingestellt sind die diesen krieg und
die politik des kremls absolut
verurteilen erika h schreibt via youtube
mein mann ist auch halb ukraine sein
vater blieb nach dem krieg hier wir
haben ihn leider nie kennengelernt das
ist quatsch die russische bevölkerung
für putin verantwortlich zu machen und
so ähnlich äußert sich auch mirko auch
via youtube nur weil der anführer mist
baut sollte man nicht auf die gehen
denen die falsche richtung durch putting
gelaufen sind um nach vorne zu schauen
was glauben sie was richtet dieser krieg
jetzt an und was wird nötig sein um das
irgendwann mal irgendwie zu heilen
der krieg richtet leider nicht mehr in
der ukraine ganz viel schlimmes an
sondern auch in russland und der ton die
menschen russland was ebenso leicht wie
die in der ukraine weil sie ja auch
unter diesen krieg leiden weil sie auch
verband in der ukraine haben und sich
auch derzeit gar nicht frei informieren
können also wissen dass wikipedia
facebook gesperrt wurde heute nacht um
mitternacht wird instagram gesperrt man
kann nicht einfach also ich weiß nicht
ob das den menschen deutschland bewusst
dass man kann ich einfach in russland
googeln und ukraine eingeben und dann
kommt die information an die bei uns
ankommen da ist alles komplett
gedrosselt und der haupt also der
hauptfaktor ist nicht google sondern jan
tags und so weiter und ich glaube das
reicht gerade sehr sehr große bunten in
familien rein und weil viele ukrainische
familie und russische familien ja
gegenseitig verwandtschaft in den
gegenseitigen ländern haben und es reißt
auch viel es bringt auch viel unruhe
nach europa und ich weiß auch dass in
familien ohne migrationsgeschichte in
deutschland sehr viel diskutiert wird
und da auch viel gestritten wird genau
zu diesem thema und ich glaube was ganz
ganz wichtig auch künftig sein wird ist
dass solche verbrechen wie sie aktuell
geschehen nicht vergessen werden und wir
sehen was in russland passiert ist putin
hat ein die nahrungs kultur lahmgelegt
er hat die geschichte umgeschrieben
indem er einfach auch
menschenrechtsorganisationen dem real
verboten hat die sich eben mit der
aufklärung stalinistischen verbrechen
auseinandersetzen und ist es ganz
wichtig dass weiterhin geschichte
geschichte einfach wach gehalten wird
und auch das was jetzt passiert
dokumentiert wird und auch künftig
erzählt wird und ich glaube wir müssen
dann irgendwie wieder zu einer
versöhnung finden und das wird eine
aufgabe nicht nur für uns dass jetzt
auch die aufgabe unserer kinder sein
fürchte ich und auch die aufgabe
durchaus ja von von menschen die die
hier leben zumal dieser krieg ja nicht
nur bei uns stattfindet via fernsehen in
irgendeiner form sondern mehr und mehr
flüchtlinge kommen hier wir haben zwar
gehört 3 millionen russlanddeutsche die
hier leben das heißt ein teil dieses
krieges und dieses konflikts kommt auch
immer mehr nach deutschland was können
wir denn tun was ist aus ihrer sicht
hier wichtig damit dieser krieg hier auf
deutschen boden sozusagen nicht
fortgeführt wird sondern dass man von
hier aus vielleicht so etwas wie heilen
kann im diskurs kommen kann zueinander
finden kann ja also ich glaube zum einen
was ich vorhin gesagt hat es ganz
wichtig den druck auf die politik
aufrecht zu erhalten auf demonstrationen
zu gehen und auch ganz einfach hilfe zu
leisten im kleinen also müssen es muss
ja auch nicht jeder ein interview geben
oder auf demos gehen aber jeder kann
beispielsweise spenden und ich glaube
gerade menschen die aus dem post aus
staaten kommen also post sowjetisch
geprägten mehr sprach mehrere sprachen
beherrschen so wie ich zum beispiel das
russische wir sind in einer besonderen
situation weil wir diesen menschen die
jetzt bei uns ankommen helfen können
weil wir ihre sprache und ihre kultur
besser verstehen als jemand der eben
hier geboren wurde und ich glaube es ist
die aufgabe von uns russischsprachigen
ukraine sprachigen im land hier brücken
zu bauen und genauso ist es auch die
aufgabe eines jeden menschen in
deutschland eine brücke zu bauen zu
jedem menschen nicht aus der ukraine
sondern auch zu anderen menschen die
gerade zu uns flüchten und die dürfen
wäre in dieser situation auch nicht
außer acht lassen denn die brauchen auch
unsere hilfe ihrer peter vielen dank für
diesen appell für die zeit und für die
worte und für die einsichten die wir
sozusagen auch dadurch gewinnen können
und sie haben es vorhin gesagt dass es
wichtig in diesen zeiten ins gespräch zu
kommen danke für diesen teil den sie
dazu beigetragen haben
ja wir haben gehört die hilfe und die
hilfsbereitschaft sind immens zuweilen
aber wir haben es für einen beitrag
schon gesehen und gucken noch ein
bisschen genauer hin kippt die stimmung
auch und vor allem wenn diese stimmung
kippt werden diese sachen auch
instrumentalisiert propaganda ist ein
großes wort kommen wir gleich zu denn in
kriegszeiten geht es nie um die wahrheit
die scheibe eingeschlagen die fassade
mit farbbeuteln beschmiert ein gezielter
angriff auf einen russischen supermarkt
in nordrhein westfalen die polizei geht
von einer tat vor dem hintergrund des
ukraine krieges aus der staatsschutz
ermittelt
andere fälle werden bewusst falsch
dargestellt
diese bilder zeigen beschädigte busse
eines unternehmens nahe hamburg das
video wird in sozialen medien als russen
feindliche angriffe verbreitet einen
politischen hintergrund gibt es laut
zuständiger polizei aber nicht einen
geschäftsführer mit angeblich russischen
wurzeln auch diskutieren dann
beispielsweise videos und fotos in
sozialen netzwerken wo man nicht immer
so wirklich genau weiß wo die herkommen
die aber dazu beitragen dass das ein
klima der angst und verunsicherung unter
den menschen erzeugt wird und so ein
narrativ gepusht wird dass es eben diese
massive russo phobie in deutschland gebe
eine liste ähnliche anwendungen
veröffentlicht die russische botschaft
hunderte fälle seien ihnen bereits
gemeldet worden die anonymisierten
angaben lassen sich schwer nachprüfen
ein echtes schreiben einer münchner
klinik verbreitete botschaft auf ihrem
teller gramm kanal mitte der woche die
klinik erklärt aus solidarität mit der
ukraine keine russischsprachigen
menschen mehr zu behandeln dass sich die
klinik zu diesem zeitpunkt bereits in
einer öffentlichen stellungnahme
entschuldigt hatte erwähnt die russische
botschaft aber nicht
ob sex oder echte übergriffe experten
warnen vor gezielter desinformation
andere post im netz verbreiten diesen
vermeintlichen hass brief den russisch
stämmige bewohner im baden
württembergischen trossingen erhalten
haben sollen
die deutschen medien berichten über
dieses schreiben berichten dann ist es
auf jeden fall ein anlass für sage ich
mal
aus dem spektrum der anti demokratischen
kräfte oder auch russische propaganda
auch missbraucht zu werden indem man
quasi diese diese große vorbestimmung
hier in deutschland auch legitimiert
bekommt über diese spiegelung der
deutschen medien über darauf reagiert
eine der meistgelesenen russischen
wochenzeitungen berichtet bereits über
ähnliche briefe
und jetzt bin ich verbunden mit sergej
pro kopf in sie sind blogger
aufgewachsen in russland kamen mit 17
nach deutschland sie haben jura studiert
sind aktiv für die neuen deutschen
medienmacher und uns jetzt zugeschaltet
schön dass die zeit haben gute nahm nach
berlin
wie gefährlich ist die derzeitige
stimmung wenn man auf das schaut was wir
da gerade gesehen haben
die stimmung ist gerade nicht so einfach
einzuschätzen weil es seit zwei wochen
losgeht was man so problematisieren
könnte ist der aufkommende anti
islamismus der gar nicht so neu in
deutschland ist und bietet eigentlich
einen fruchtbaren boden für das was
jetzt aufkommt und das ist der part also
ein paar bezüglich der diskriminierung
und andererseits gibt es natürlich auch
die propaganda des kremls die sich jetzt
versagen verbreitet und viele menschen
verunsichert wie gerade herr panagiotis
das gesagt hat wir schauen gleich auf
die interessen aber vielleicht erstmal
auf diejenigen die es betrifft was
erleben sie was hören sie in ihren blogs
die sie machen wie sind sie aufgestellt
momentan die gegner putins einerseits
und andererseits die anhänger
auf meinen blogs bekomme ich häufiger
private nachrichten da handelt sich
meistens um fälle von mobbing oder
beschimpfungen bzw beleidigungen die
vielleicht sogar strafrechtlich relevant
werden
so massenhaft kommen diese meldungen
nicht allerdings ist es wichtig trotzdem
menschen ernst zu nehmen und alle fälle
zu überprüfen
es gibt nämlich so eine solche tendenz
bei bestimmten menschengruppen
diskriminierung nicht einzunehmen und er
darauf zu schauen
ob propaganda das ausnutzt oder nicht so
dass diskriminieren die betroffenen
menschen schnell aus dem fokus geraten
und da müssen wir auf jeden fall
aufpassen wir haben es vorhin schon
gehört von ihrer peter wie ist es bei
ihnen persönlich welche gräben erleben
sie von welchen von männchen
verwendungen hören sie was passiert da
gerade auch innerhalb von familien
der es gibt tatsächlich
einerseits unterschiedliche perspektiven
unter postsowjetischen migrantinnen und
da gibt es schattierungen wie einerseits
putin gegner dann und menschen die gegen
den krieg sind und andererseits gibt es
verfechterin vom krieg es gibt die
menschen die auch in der älteren
generation
gegen den krieg sind und es gibt
menschen die eher unentschlossen sind
die vielleicht auch putting seite meine
warnung aber seit dem beginn des
angriffskriegs er bot ihnen den rücken
kehren oder bzw gerade sehr verunsichert
sind
reden wir über bilder was sie machen und
was man mit ihnen machen kann und
schauen uns vielleicht mal aktuelle
bilder an von der vergangenen nacht bei
ihnen aus berlin an einer
deutsch-russischen privatschule in
marzahn wurde vergangene nacht ein brand
gelegt der brandsatz wurde am eingang
der turnhalle gezündet alles in allem
ging es glimpflich aus die
kriminalpolizei geht von einem
politischen motiv aus der staatsschutz
ermittelt
insgesamt verzeichnet allein berlin
momentan 100 straftaten beleidigung
schmierereien oder zu sehen die meisten
sind an die russisch ein kleiner teil
auch ist gegen die ukraine gerichtet was
mich jetzt interessiert an der stelle
inwiefern werden solche bilder solche
informationen und das was da in
ausnahmefällen passiert
instrumentalisiert
es gab schon jetzt kurz in der meldung
zu der russischen botschaft die
explizite bevölkerung große sprachige
bevölkerung nicht russischsprachige
anspricht und bietet um hilfe damit
diese fälle gemeldet werden diese fälle
werden allerdings nicht jetzt weiter an
die diskriminierung stellen oder polizei
weitergeleitet sondern tatsächlich für
die russische propaganda verwendet und
zum beispiel die beauftrage
regierungsbeauftragte maskawa aus
russland die beschweren sich jetzt bei
dem europarat und macht erstmal aus
einer mücke einen elefanten bevor
überhaupt irgendwas passiert anstatt
menschen zu helfen es geht nicht darum
betroffene zu unterstützen sondern
politik zu machen und die botschaft
spielt auf jeden fall eine ganz große
rolle und die vermitteln das gefühl dass
russland sich um die menschen gekümmert
und andererseits versuchen sie natürlich
die stimmung des misstrauens der angst
zu schüren also es geht auch da nicht um
aufklärung sondern das wird
instrumentalisiert das heißt es werden
beispiele gesucht um sie zu nutzen zu
benutzen ja genau so ist es weil es gibt
kaum vorschläge für konkrete schritte es
gibt natürlich so meldungen dass
russland sich beschwert hat bei dem
auswärtigen amt in deutschland aber das
sind wiederum fälle dieser medial
ausgeschlachtet werden von den
staatlichen medien in russland genommen
kommen wir auf die medien zu sprechen
welche rolle spielen sie bei all dem
um die
russischsprachigen medien so
staatsmedien spielten bisher eine
ziemlich große rolle vor allem für die
menschen die
mit nicht so guten kenntnissen in
deutsch kenntnissen nach deutschland
kamen und
vor allem russisches fernsehen
konsumiert haben
und wahrscheinlich lag es teilweise
daran
dass
das angebot von russisch sprechen medien
in deutschland damit zu gering war so
dass menschen darauf zurückgegriffen
haben
und ich glaube diese medien spielen
immer noch eine rolle einige werden
jetzt
gesperrt auf plattformen wie kann man
aber immer noch erreichen über
alternative links und
abermals leicht genau dazu also wenn man
sie jetzt sozusagen sich nicht auf
staatliche fernsehsender wohnen will
welche welche alternativen gibt es denn
derzeit tatsächlich noch
es gibt tatsächlich blogger die als
putin anhänger einen propaganda weiter
verbreiten inzwischen werden influenza
in eingeschaltet so dass sie für den
krieg werben
da sind die dimensionen die auch das
junge publikum erreicht und es gibt zwei
richtungen einerseits natürlich menschen
in europa sowie sprachige bevölkerung zu
verunsichern und andererseits das bild
vom in anführungszeichen bösen westen in
russland zu propagieren damit die
bevölkerung in russland sieht dass die
bevölkerung in europa euro sofort ist
also ein islamistisch würde ich das eher
beschreiben
und sich vom besten einfach oder von
europa weiter entfernt es können ja
immer zwei dazu würde ich mal sagen das
eine ist was man an propaganda raus gibt
das andere auf welch offene ohren das
alles stößt das heißt will man manchmal
auch hören was man eben hören will also
wird dort gesendet was sowieso auf
fruchtbaren boden fällt oder ist es so
dass die propaganda aus ihrer sicht
funktioniert und dass dann eben erst
ermöglicht das ist ja ein unterschied
die propaganda stößt auf jeden fall bei
vielen auch wenn der ohren weil es
häufig etwas mit identität zu tun hat
ich beobachte dass jüngere menschen die
in deutschland geboren oder aufgewachsen
sind der russländischen propaganda eher
weniger verfallen sind als die ältere
generation und da gibt es ansprachen an
die ältere generation vor allem
die menschen das gefühl der
zugehörigkeit gibt häufig ist als so
postsowjetischer die politische rhetorik
vielleicht so sehn sucht nach größe
vielleicht
die familie oder
junges alter und es gibt unterschiedlich
dann verpackt und
und weiter gesagt hat ich habe es
eingangs gesagt der kreml hat heute
verlauten lassen dass für eine rose
phobie zu warnen sei der sprecher
dimitri peskow kritisiert zugleich
landsleute als russische landsleute die
sich kritisch äußern einem echten russen
ist es nie peinlich russisch zu sein
wenn jemand so redet dann heißt das dass
er kein russe ist das heißt wird er auch
an diese instinkte appelliert
wir auf jeden fall also da geht es
konkret um die identität und es gibt
menschen die
über sich mit russland über
identifizieren obwohl sie gar nicht zum
beispiel mit russland was zu tun hatten
menschen die aus kasachstan kommen
trotzdem putin preuß und und die
russische propaganda fehlt natürlich auf
diese menschen ab und
discos aussage ist eine gute bestätigung
dafür aus ihrer sicht was ist das ziel
alters
in das ziel ist klar
erstens durch angst und misstrauen
die bevölkerung in deutschland
so weit es geht zu spalten zu
verunsichern weil für unsicherheit der
bevölkerung ist nicht so handlungsfähig
wie ein bevölkerung die am gleichen
strang zieht und wir merken dass diese
fehler des rassismus fehle die
vermischen sich mit den fällen der
propaganda das heißt es kauf sagt in
deutschland gibt es diskriminierung die
gibt es tatsächlich und gleichzeitig
gibt es fälle die es gar nicht gegeben
hat und diese mischung aus realität und
propaganda macht das ganze
brandgefährlich weil menschen habe ich
das gar nicht unterscheiden können oder
nicht die kompetenzen haben fällt news
von tatsächlichen fällen
naja zu unterscheiden direkt dazu bei
wem aus ihrer sicht fruchtet das
ich würde sagen dass vor allem bei
älteren menschen also die generation
unter mir also meine eltern und eltern
50 würde ich die generationen
beschreiben und da kann man natürlich
weiter unterscheiden nach
klasse oder bildungsstand und so weiter
ich beobachte bei den jüngeren menschen
vor allem weil menschen die akademischen
hintergrund haben dass sie viel weniger
für propaganda anfällig sind und viel
aktiver sich gegen den krieg und gegen
putin stellen aber auch da gibt es
durchaus bemühungen sie haben mir vor
der sendung von einer band leningrad
erzählt
es gibt eine ziemlich populär aber
tatsächlich auch umstrittener dass
russland da heißt leningrad und
jetzt gestern glaube ich kann meinen
text rein video music video aus wo sie
also kurz beschreiben dass ein user
schreibt dass er diskriminiert wird und
die trainer alles wirklich alles so dass
die großen in europa wie
juden und jüdinnen im jahr 1940
behandelt wurden im hintergrund auf dem
videobild stehen menschen in
traditionelle russischer kleid und mit
davidstern auf den händen und am ende
wird gesagt okay der
genozid an der russischen bevölkerung in
europa geht schritt für schritt weiter
das heißt diese apokalyptische stimmung
wird jetzt auch durch die
kulturelle beiträge verbreitet so
aufgegriffen und verbreitet wenn man das
alles sieht es ist ja nicht nur die
zerstörung im land in der ukraine
sondern eben auch mit diesen
verwerfungen die damit einhergeht was
macht der krieg alles kaputt
also hier sprechen wir auf jeden fall
von hybriden krieg bzw einer hybriden
kriegsführung und es heißt das ist nicht
direkt ein bewaffneter konflikt hier
stattfindet sondern zum beispiel mit
hilfe von desinformation oder stiftung
von chaos in die gesellschaft
eingegriffen wird um die gesellschaft
weniger handlungsfähig zu machen
dazu muss ich aber sagen dass die
erfolge des informations krieges gerade
relativ geringer sind wenn wir uns zum
beispiel den fall lisa anschauen von
2016 da hatte ich das gefühl dass dieser
fall viel mehr menschen erreicht hat und
so dass viel mehr menschen in der not
entstanden gerade verliert putin seine
anhängerschaft in deutschland dass der
westen dass die nato aber dass auch die
ganzen angrenzenden länder zur ukraine
so entschlossen dagegen stehen was von
russland momentan ausgeht diesen
angriffskrieg sich entgegenstellen das
heißt das aber auch umgekehrt für
diejenigen die sowieso einen ich sag mal
einen kritischen blick auf den westen
haben wie sehr werden die gräben die es
gibt noch mal vertieft und was könnte
eine brücke sein
zunächst habe ich zumindest den eindruck
dass putin bzw der kreml versucht einen
tiefen graben zwischen europa und
russland zu graben insbesondere was die
werte wie menschenrechte angeht der
austritt aus dem europarat nun von
russland ist ein beispiel dafür
und diese gräben würden wahrscheinlich
jetzt noch tiefer werden
mit dem fortschreiten des krieges und
wie wir die brücken bauen können da
müssen wir tatsächlich unterscheiden und
für dann von putins anhänger entsprechen
oder von menschen die nicht auf seite
von toten sind
gerade beobachtet vor allem in berlin
dass viele menschen aus dem deutschen
community post austin mini die
politischen community sich sehr viel
engagieren zum beispiel bei der
unterstützung von geflüchteten oder bei
ständen oder bei
redebeiträgen und
david es einfache diese gräben
flach zu halten bzw nicht gratis lassen
wie das mit der ausländischen
bevölkerung in russland und ukraine
enden dann später aussieht das kann ich
gerade noch nicht sagen aber es ist
normal dass wenn es ist auch noch sehr
früh noch tobt dieser krieg und
natürlich ist es schwer jetzt schon zu
schauen was eines tages vielleicht an
besserung kommen wird oder wie man es
besser machen kann sergej prokofjew
danke für die zeit danke für diese
einblicke und die informationen danke
nach berlin und sehr gerne
das war es auch schon wieder ist heute
live eine gute halbe stunde
und glaube ich die erkenntnis dass man
sich wirklich zuhören muss dass wir alle
die dringlichkeit in uns haben werden
müssen einander zuzuhören und wieder
aufeinander zuzugehen um diesen krieg
nicht wirklich auch im herzen toben zu
lassen und die möglichkeit zu bieten
eine bessere zukunft für diejenigen die
in die ukraine auch wieder zurück wollen
die dort leben wollen die nachbarschaft
leben wollen das auch künftig tun zu
können in diesem sinne danke für eure
aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss